What do we eat today without leaving your home?
Ursula,
88 years old,
has found another way to avoid feeling alone.
He shares his apartment with Marina for the second season,
20 years old,
double- student
social and sociology.
Both have taken advantage of the program
shared accommodation of the upo
1 intergenerational experience that brings them together
more than anything else.
She is my friend and we tell each other all the things.
and if I am sick for 1 day or whatever,
I know I can share it with Ella
and that it's like she's my friend
but with more knowledge and more life ahead of him.
Give the doll?
Um,
that's fine
and I'm waiting for it to eat
and we talk a lot while eating.
And then something else
She to me.
Here I closed all the doors,
locked everything
and now she is in 1 room and I am in another one.
and I feel very good